[Music]
what hello and once again we welcome you
to another edition of I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
here at some TV and we are just pleased
to have this opportunity to speak with
you to dialogue with you and I say
dialogue because we get to answer your
questions as you send them in from
really around the world as we study the
word of God Together As We join together
it gives us an understanding of those
issues that you may have that you want
to discuss and it sort of focuses our
our study as we try to answer your
questions from the word of God and we
say this almost each program and perhaps
it's becoming a bit old for those of you
who hear it often but for those of you
who may be new we guarantee you that
we're going to answer your questions
from the word of God now we say that
because I watched programs I guess we
all have where answers don't come from
the word of God where people are sort of
making them up as they go along and
sometimes I hear answers and I wonder
what part of the Bible those answers are
in uh because that happens so we make
you this guarantee so that we're not
wasting our time nor are we wasting your
time which we respect to answer your
questions as they are found in the word
of God if an answer can indeed be found
we will try to find it and give it to
you because what we need in these last
days just prior to the second coming of
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ is a
word from the Lord and we wish to give
you that word and nothing but that true
word from the Lord so that promise we
make to you if you will but write us we
ask you to do so at
TVM tv.org that is
TV susum as in Mar
tv.org and we promise to get to your
questions just as soon as we can the
stack is rather impressive and we like
it that way we want a lot of questions
so it gives us a chance to do a lot of
study to answer those questions and um
we will get to them we promise you as we
work our way through the stack we'll get
to your questions sooner or later so
stay with us because we will answer your
questions we promise Pastor David
Salazar if you would ask the Lord's
blessing on this program we shall launch
out into today's question amen let's
pray gracious heavenly father as we come
before you at this hour we thank you
first of all for allowing us to come to
you and to understand that you are the
source of all wisdom of all truth truth
and as you speak through your word we
ask simply that your Holy Spirit be the
one that comes uh in our midst and uses
our minds our thoughts or words so that
the answers May reach those that are
watching and listening and the answers
may come from your word I pray all of
these in Jesus holy name amen amen I
don't know if I took the the opportunity
to introduce our distinguished panel you
know these guys it's not like they're
strangers by any stretch uh to my left
is Pastor Steven B the founder and
principal speaker for suam TV uh Pastor
as always love to study the word of God
with you and to be on this program with
you I love studying the word and I love
doing the program with you amen praise
the Lord and as we introduce Pastor
David Salazar is our general manager of
su TV Latino busy guy uh working hard
for the Lord Pastor good to have you
here thank you Pastor for having me here
as well as a blessing as always all
righty let's launch out Jackie
uh writes us she doesn't tell us where
she's writing from and we want to
encourage you let us know where you're
writing from if if it's not too much of
an inconvenience because we like to know
where this program is going and the
lives that we are touching she says
hello pastors my Bible question is this
if Jesus is the only way truth and the
life and the only way to the father why
do we hear that many sincere Christians
in denominations that teach undoin views
will be saved for example someone who
might be very sincere but still deceived
by Faith by works or faith with no
change or commandment or keeping of The
Commandments just asking for more
clarity I like the comforting idea but I
want to know the
truth so she wants to know uh about
truth and error and people believing
that will they and can they indeed be
saved uh who wants to launch out for
that one well I can start and um I know
that you probably will join as well in
the conversation well there is this
question that she has absolutely Jesus
is the truth the way and the life and we
understand that knowing Christ is the
only way to be saved now her concern
about those who are not believing or do
not understand the scriptures or do not
understand the all the truth what about
them well first of all
we have to go to the Book of John and I
would like to read you know these this
verse that we all know very well and
it's verse 16 you know that it says for
God so of the world that he gave his
only begotten son that whosoever
believeth in him should not perish but
have everlasting life so there you have
the essence of believing in Jesus now
the question is Verse 18 tells us and 18
tells us something about what it means
to Believe In Christ he says he that
believeth on him is not condemned so
when I Believe In Christ I'm not
condemned but he that believeth not is
condemned already because he had not
believed in the name of the only
begotten Son of God and this is the
condemnation that light is coming to the
world and Men love Darkness rather than
light because their deeds were evil so
God will judge people according to the
light they receive and it's not the
problem of you know uh believing in
Jesus believe all the light you have if
you believe in all the light that you
receive you will be saved but if you
choose to ignore the truth or choose not
to listen to the light that God is
giving you besides you know just if I
pick and choose this I believe I don't
believe the rest then you are actually
choosing darkness and in that you are
condemned now the spirit of Prophecy
also speaks in uh you know many several
passages and I will just to read one
that's found in the book um later Day
events last day events which is Page
217 and it says None will be condemned
for not heing light and knowledge that
they never had and they could not obtain
but many refuse to obey the truth that
is presented to them by Christ
ambassadors because they wish to conform
to the world's standard and the truth
that has reached their understanding the
light that has Shone in the soul will
condemn them in the Judgment so it is
not you know the fact that they are not
believing in a part of the Gospel but
they don't want to believe in everything
and if you have received that light by
rejecting the light you are condemned
and so this is why I think that it's
important that we we you know answer
this question to her that it is not
those that did not know any better that
not know any more they will be judged to
their light they receive but if you
receive the light and reject it then you
are condemned for loving Darkness rather
than the light M MH I like that um I
like the idea that that sometimes we we
volitionally remain in darkness we
remain in darkness not because there is
no light to be found but because men
love Darkness because their deeds are
evil we want to stay in darkness um
someone brings you a Bible and that
Bible collects dust on your table you
should have read that Bible um someone
invites you to an Evangelistic Crusade
or a meeting uh you could have gone to
that meeting so there there are
opportunities and the Lord will not
allow someone to be lost with no
opportunity whatsoever uh to know about
the gospel but but the truth is
sometimes we just don't want to know I
remember I was preaching to woman came
to me she said I just didn't believe
this sabbath thing but the truth is I
didn't want to know you know I didn't I
didn't want to know I I I I know the
truth but I didn't want to know the
truth I just want wanted to but now I'm
convicted so now I've got to respond
well once you know you have to do
Pastor the bottom line is that there is
no Protestant that I know of that
doesn't have the
Bible anyone who is
Sincere has an open heart and an open
mind can read the Bible and reach sound
conclusions as to what you're supposed
to do and what you're not supposed to do
mhm
the problem is that most people who
attend church depend on their Pastor for
their view of
Salvation and you cannot depend on any
human being for anything regarding the
word of God Christians have to go to the
word of God themselves they need to
study what the Bible says about about
salvation we are not saved by the light
that we receive we are saved by the use
that we make of the light that we
receive and if we had the opportunity to
receive the light and rejected the
opportunity that God gave us we're still
accountable in the sight of God yes and
so uh it's very very uh serious to
reject the light because once you reject
it it becomes easier to reject it the
next time and then the next time until
eventually you end up in darkness and
you didn't don't even know that you
ended up in darkness now uh this
question um towards the end of the
question uh says that there are some
Christians that believe that they'll be
saved by their Works other Christians
believe that they will be saved by by
their faith the fact is that no one will
be saved by their works or by their own
faith necessarily On and nobody will be
saved by naked faith without works right
Ellen White in great controversy wrote
that the papacy caters to two groups mhm
those who believe that they can be saved
by their merits MH that's one ditch and
the other is that they can believe that
they will be saved in their sins so by
their merits or in their sins two
ditches now uh if you're driving down a
road you know on a wintry day and uh
it's snowing like crazy yeah and your
car begins to slide and slip which ditch
would you rather fall into the right
ditch or the left ditch the bottom line
is you're in the same boat whether
you're in either ditch so the devil
doesn't care if we think that we can sa
be saved by our works he doesn't care if
we believe that we can be saved in our
sins yes uh as long as we're in one of
the ditches the bottom line is that true
Faith yeah Works amen and if it's not a
working Faith it's the counterfeit of
Faith amen amen I think there is a
difference between what we could have
have known should have known what we had
no opportunity to know and God is aware
of that as as you intimated uh Pastor
Salazar
um the truth is and and I I thank you
Pastor B because you have boldly gone
where I was not going to go but now that
you've gone
there you have my permission we can mind
it the truth is some of us are too
Pastor Centric the Bible says in second
Timothy study to show thyself approved I
don't know how many people say well
Pastor what's the answer to this
question well that's that's too easy
that's that's drawing on my knowledge
you need to draw from your own knowledge
and and truth be told uh dear
Brethren everybody my mother used to say
every tub has the rest on its own bottom
you know that was my mother had all
these say sayings this is saying saying
saying saying that was one of them
basically everybody has to stand for
themselves amen um and and your your
ability to stand is going to be tested
you've got to know the the word of God
for yourself if you don't know the word
of God for yourself you don't even know
what promises to claim when you get in
hot water that's true so studying helps
you it makes you stronger um and and and
you you cannot be so Pastor Centric that
whatever your pastor says you just take
it the Bible says test the spirits try
the spirits see if they line up with the
word of God and if you're in a church
that is not preaching the whole truth
then you need to jettison that church
and find one that does Amen you have
that you're you're you're basing your
life your future your eternity on your
belief system so you need to make sure
that your belief system lines up with
the word of God truth be told there are
very few people in the United States
there are very few Protestants who have
no knowledge of Jesus Christ whatsoever
so once you've got the Christ knowledge
the the next thing is what is the
doctrinal package that lines up with
that knowledge so that you're are doing
what the Bible asks you to do and that
Brothers brothers and sisters is on you
you've got to study the word of God
you've got to turn off the TV turn off
some of these things open up your Bible
if you do it on computer that's fine but
spend the requisite time in the word of
God to fortify yourself so that you're
prepared for the trials which I
guarantee you are going to come your way
so you want to be on the right side
doing the right thing when Christ comes
uh that is your only guarantee to to
Salvation bottom line is many people
cannot answer the devil it is written
because they don't know where it's
written ah or even worse they can't
answer it is written because they don't
even know if it is written uh you know
the bottom line is that our only weapon
besides prayer for um temptation is to
study for ourselves study for yourself
to show yourself approved and so that's
what we encourage people to do here and
I'd like to know we do answer people's
questions but uh you need to go to your
Bible and you need to see if the answers
that we are providing yes are in harmony
with scripture even we encourage you to
check us out absolutely uh because no
human being uh is infallible absolutely
and so we need to make sure that we
study for ourselves that is why 2
Timothy 4:3 speaks that you know
speaking of today I especially believe
that is for the time will come when they
will not endure sound Doctrine but after
their own lust shall they keep to
themselves teachers having each and
years yes and I believe that a lot of
Christians today sadly are looking unto
men to preach to them things that make
them feel comfortable in whatever
condition they want you know if if you
believe in righteousness by works you
know doing your own work you'll find
somebody that speaks to you in that way
and if you feel that you can be content
in sin and be still okay in heaven then
you going to follow somebody that
teaches you that and preaches to you
that but ultimately it comes it depends
on us individually to seek for ourselves
the truth and realize that the sound
Doctrine is you know something that we
have to accept endure and many will not
want to endure that sound Doctrine you
amen amen the imagery there is of people
who have an itch yes in their ears and
they need somebody to do the scratching
and so the pastor is the one who
scratches the itch yeah but but we
should not be interested in having
somebody scratch our it we should be
intent on letting the Bible determine
what we study and what we practice amut
amen someone wrote in just the other day
um I think I had misquoted a text and
they caught me and they wrote it and
they said that that text you quoted was
not the right text so we got the right
text to them we like that uh because
we're not we don't we're not perfect
sometimes we we misspeak or we say a
text wrong uh that means you're
listening and we don't mind when you
call in and ask for Corrections uh or or
further and we've had times when we had
to re-explain something or further
explain something that that happens also
that uh is no burden for us we like to
do that and we thank you so uh good
question and uh we thank you Jackie for
that there is a question from last week
from Brian that we did not uh deal with
that has to do with baptism I wanted to
go back and get that question um as I
recall Brian was saying that he was
baptized as a teen right and he was
asking did he need to be re-baptized now
what what struck me what sort of jumped
out at me was the fact that he didn't
name any particular sins or infractions
just that his baptism was many many
years ago uh so let's pick it up from
there and uh sort of walk away walk our
way through it I think that one of the
things that he Brian needs to remember
is that
uh if he was sincere in his baptism and
H baptism meant something to him as he
gave his himself to the Lord um unless
he really did a public offense to the
church name and his life if he Wonder
off and live a life that publicly
Express you know a rebellion to the Lord
uh this there's not really a need to be
baptized as he can go through the
communion process and that will basic
basically reintegrate him to that
communion with God as he partakes of
that communion you know uh right with
with in the church so I would suggest to
him that you know if his sins wander him
off really from the path of
righteousness and and it was became a
public knowledge that he went against
the Lord and maybe he had some issues or
some sins that really were offensive to
the to those around and they know about
it it will be a testimony for for
everybody for him to turn back to the
church and be back baptized in that
scenario I would say that he uh should
consider that if that's what he is
impressed by the Lord to do um other
than that um you know if he nobody knows
about it and he has lived somewhat a
life that his sins are private then I
really don't see the need unless he of
course feels compelled to do such such
decision you know but I don't see the
need I don't know Pastor Bo maybe has
more an and more you know as I agree
100% um as I travel mhm invariably I
have um individuals who were baptized
when they were children that come up to
me they're not now youth or adults and
they say Pastor bore uh when I got
baptized I didn't really know what I was
doing um I was baptized because my
parents pressured me to get baptized or
I got baptized because my peers were
being baptized or because my pastor
twisted my arm but I didn't you know I
was just going to be dunked under the
water I didn't really understand what I
was doing right uh do you think that I
should get re-baptized and my counsel to
them is if you're going through a
ceremony without understanding what the
ceremony means I mean that that doesn't
do anything for you you know baptism
means that you knowingly recognize
yourself a sinner right and you're
burying your past you're receiving the
righteousness of Christ for the
Forgiveness of your sins and so uh just
getting dunked under the water without
understanding what's happening I've
recommended to uh these Youth and adults
some of them right I say if it didn't
mean anything to you uh definitely get
re-baptized now that you understand what
it means right and uh it doesn't involve
any specific sin like you were
mentioning which became a P public
spectable spectacle to the church uh but
uh and some of them have done it and
it's been a very meaningful experience
to them amen yeah I was baptized as a
child I think I was nine I think I had a
pretty good handle on what I was doing
but I felt once I got to college after
my teen years I call them those
Wilderness years I wanted to uh to be re
baptized again little more understanding
start a little more consecration uh and
I did it again um and of course we we we
have a a
um an example in Acts 19: 2-4 of
rebaptism once you come into greater
knowledge it wasn't that the folk had
been sinning particularly right but they
came into a great anal and they re
baptized now you introduced an element
that I want to just mind for just a
second uh Pastor saladar because you
talked about communion so let's for
those who may not be familiar with that
element as asby speaks private sins or
private things that happen in our lives
walk me through that and Pastor Bor feel
free to jump in on this also if you wish
right the the communion right is is
taking of the remembering first of all
the sacri sacrifice of Christ in the
cross and we partake of his the symbols
of his body in the bread un leaven bread
and the uh pure juice of of the of the
grapes symbolizing his blood so those
two symbols and that communion service
as we partake also the washing the feet
it's what Christ instituted as a way for
us to
entering that communion experience where
we recognize our sinfulness we re REM
meditate on this on the cause of
Christ's death which is our sins and
that brings us in that experience of
coming to Christ confessing our sins
confessing sins to one another and
really binding us to him even closer so
that experience is like a an experience
of re reuniting with him communion with
him coming back if we were away from the
communion with Christ we are back in
that fold if you will in that communion
with Christ so someone who has gone
through an experience who is already
baptized and who has gone through the
experience of maybe doing things in
their lives things that they have in
their hearts turned away from the Lord
and rejected the Lord that communion
experience that moment when you do it of
course consciously and realizing your
need of Christ becomes a blessing and in
a in a in a sense it renews
that commitment that you made to the
Lord in your day of baptism so it's it's
in that sense it becomes another
experience for you to you know be born
again again if you will be born again
once more so that's what it would do
yeah the the reaffirmation of
baptism uh is in the ordinance of
humility I don't like to call it foot
washing because it has to do with Wasing
the heart and your mind your feet but
the ordinance of humility is meant to to
prepare us to partake of the table of
the Lord MH El white says that that the
Affliction mhm and the
humiliation takes place at at the
washing of the feet or at the ordinance
of humility and once you have been
emptied of that selfishness in the
ordinance of humility which is kind of
like baptism you're born a new you start
all over again right then you're ready
to go to the table of the Lord and Ellen
White states that you know when we go to
the table of the lord we should beong
fac and oh I'm such a sinner you did
that in the ordinance of humility now
you're going to go to the table she says
with joy with happiness to to focus on
the wonderful things that Jesus did for
you and you know most churches do not
practice the ordinance of humility the
Adventist Church is one of the few
churches that practices it even though
yeah even though Jesus three times yes
yes stated that it needs to be
celebrated in John 13 mhm and verse uh
14 after he washes the disciples feet he
says if I then your lord and teacher
have washed your feet you also ought to
wash one another's feet yes then the
very next verse second time for I have
given you an example that you should do
as I have done to you and then in verse
17 if you know these things blessed are
you if you do them amen and so it's it's
an enigma to me why churches will go to
the communion table without uh the
Affliction and the ordinance of humility
which is the preparation for being at
the table of the Lord and as you
mentioned Pastor is a way to also give
that cleansing you know experience as we
Wasing it's it's sort it reminds us of
of the you know Christ cleansing Our
Lives sort of what what happens with
going into the baptism you know you are
cleansed by water and it's a symbol of
that that you are cleansed from your
sins and so it really connects and it
becomes a substitute in a sense of
baptism to those that have Wonder off
and when to come back to the communion
with the Lord amen now that we've gone
to this gives me a chance to ride a
horse that it's a personal horse uh this
is not something that I that I I
mandating for the church at all is that
a high
horse well I'll let you decide um um my
wife and I one of the things that has
happened in churches lately is um
husband and wife washing each other's
feet as part of community we don't we
don't do that we always wash other
people's feet for this reason um it is
nothing big it is no Act of humility to
wash my wife's feet unless you've had a
fight with her
yeah yeah yeah we'll take care of that
before we got to church praise the Lord
do but that's not that that's not a big
I mean as as husband and wife I've been
sick I've had open heart surgery I've
had prostate surgery and she's had we we
have done much more than washing other's
feet so washing other's feet is no big
deal for us right the humility comes in
finding a stranger and and Performing
that act for them so we don't do each
other's feet because someone asked me
about this they said why don't you do it
and I explained it explain to them
because it's not that's not an ex
humility for me to wash Irma's feet nor
her mind so that's a personal thing I
don't suggest that for the world but I
know that it's coming into Vogue for
husbands and wives to watch each other's
feet and we just we just done um uh we
had community just a couple weeks ago
and interestingly enough my stepdaughter
made the community bread for the first
time in her life she was so excited it
was very very good as a matter of fact
but at Communion we split up I found an
older gentleman who was the first time
coming to church to do it and uh my wife
found uh another woman and uh we had a
very wonderful time with them just a
little personal thing that uh I thought
I'd throw out there again our time is
gone we love studying the word of God
unfortunately our time has gone we'll
see you again next time God bless you
stay well keep studying his sacred
[Music]
word